hundreds of thousands of nurses have  decided to go on strike for the first  time in their Union's 100 Year history  they say they simply aren't being paid  enough that their real wages have fallen  behind the cost of living they want more  money because they say so many nurses  are leaving the profession that their  workloads have increased and they're  working under extreme pressure we don't  know what the strikes will actually look  like but we do know that emergency and  Urgent Care will continue unaffected but  there will be disruption to elective  care and routine appointments we don't  know what dates the strikes will take  place on but further details are being  announced over the coming days